-My next guest
is a talented performer
and "New York Times"
best-selling author.
He has a new Audible Original
called "Revelation:
Connecting with the Sacred
in Everyday Life,"
which is available
starting Thursday,
exclusively on Audible.
Here is Russell Brand!
-Oh, my goodness.
That's the real deal.
Look at --
That's what I'm talking about.
That is a stud right there.
Russell Brand,
it's so great to see you.
Thank you for doing this.
-It's an honor to come on your
television program with you
to discuss this "Revelation"
book that I've written,
Audible Original.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It feels like you have to
legally say "Audible Original."
-No, no, that's just
naturally how I speak.
These are just my natural
speech rhythms.
I say, "Audible Original."
For me, it's a natural
thing to say.
What is a book?
What is the point in a book?
What have they ever done for us?
-[ Laughing ] What is going on?
I want to talk --
-See that in the background?
That's satire.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I missed you, buddy.
I want to talk --
-They're all Audible Originals,
that little lot.
-[ Laughing ] That's not true.
That's not true.
These are --
I want to talk about this.
This is a big deal.
"Revelation," Audible Original.
The original vision
you had for this
is very different
than what you ended up with.
Can you talk about
what the original plan
for "Revelation" was?
-Yeah, my plan was to travel
'round the world,
and while doing that,
I was going to meet people,
learn the secrets of the sacred,
so that I could realize
and actualize myself.
Along the way, I was planning
to do a lot of handshaking
and exchange spores orally
with wise people.
Then there was a little, old
event called coronavirus-19
that really put a spanner
in the works, Jimmy.
So I was reduced to sort of
sitting on my own meditating
and trying to contact
the divine that way.
-How would you describe this?
How would you describe
"Revelation?"
-"Revelation" is --
And this is a tough one, really,
because let's face it --
I'm on your TV show
to promote an Audible Original.
It's that there is no sanctuary,
no peace, no glory,
no connection
unless we journey within --
that the reason the world is
fragmenting, fracturing,
falling apart is because we've
become lost in an illusion.
[ Chuckling ] That's why I've
come on your television program
to promote it to you.
[ Laughter ]
-Throughout "Revelation," you
talk a lot about the pandemic.
And like me, you have
two young daughters at home.
What was lockdown like
with two kids
under the age of 5?
-Well, Jimmy, that was
a revelation in itself.
It's because --
What it's like
to have two young daughters
is like experiencing
extremely powerful love
laced with devastating rudeness.
[ Laughter ]
-By you or your daughters?
I'm sorry, just to clarify.
-Well, I really, really try
my best to remain level-headed.
You know, like, say if you want
to leave a place, and they say,
"I'm not leaving this place!
I'm not leaving!"
And you go, "It's okay for you
to want to stay at the party,
and I hear that you want
to stay at the party,
but we do have to leave."
What my daughter said is,
"You're a [bleep]"
-Oh, hey, wait, wait --
[ Laughter ]
-What in the world?
-My dog's trying to get in.
Let him in.
-Can your dog do any tricks,
Russell?
-[ Chuckles ] Yeah, kind of.
Come in here.
-[ Whistling ]
-Not new ones. Bear, come in.
-Oh, sorry.
-[ Whistles ]
Bear is the name of your dog?
-Yeah, there he is, look.
Here he is.
-Aww. Bear.
Bear, Bear --
-Isn't he magnificent?
-Sit, Bear, sit.
Oh, look at that!
That's amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Russell, if your parenting's
anything like your dog training,
you have nothing to worry about,
my friend.
Um, Russell, I wanted to ask you
a quick thing,
if you don't mind.
I think I'd like to,
if you don't mind,
teach me a breathing exercise.
Is that okay?
So anyone at home would like
to learn how to relax.
-Okay, this is a very simple
breathing exercise
that was taught to me
by a great teacher.
Her name is Biet Simkin.
Sit your ass down on your heels,
if you would be so kind.
-Oh, to do this.
-This breathing exercise,
you could experience
a glimpse of the divine.
I think you could experience
the temporary suspension
of your ego.
-Are you just making me "sit,"
like Bear? I feel like Bear.
[ Laughter ]
-When you inhale, Jim,
you got to inhale very,
very deeply into your belly,
as if you're pregnant
with oxygen itself, okay?
This is what an inhale
would look like.
[ Inhales sharply ]
With the chin pointing skyward,
okay?
So you inhale like this,
filling the belly.
And when you exhale,
you fall forward
[Exhales sharply] like that,
and you collapse into it, okay?
So we inhale like this.
[ Inhales sharply ]
And you'll exhale --
[ Exhales sharply ]
Collapse forward and relax.
-I think I felt it.
-No, Jimmy, that's not it.
This is -- That's not it.
This is -- Allow me to take you
to the next level.
So, you do three inhalations
like that,
where you fill your belly.
[ Breathing sharply ]
And on the fourth inhalation,
you stand on your knees
like that, okay? You thrust up.
Sorry for that shot.
I'm so sorry for that shot.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it's like --
Like Elvis the Presley,
Elvis the pelvis.
It's all been undone.
It's coming reverse.
Let me move back a bit.
-Yep.
-Alright, Jim, so,
the fourth one is the big one.
You got to really pull it in.
So, inhale.
[ Inhales sharply ]
Push the belly out. Exhale.
Inhale. [ Inhales sharply ]
Push the belly out.
Exhale. Inhale.
[ Inhales sharply ]
Push the belly out.
And on this one, stand up
on the knees, the inhale.
Hold it. Pump the belly out.
Pump the belly out. Now exhale.
[ Exhales sharply ]
-Alright, thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
-Jim, you should feel
a lot closer to God.
-Russell Brand, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I hope you feel healed.
-Russell Brand, everyone.
"Revelation: Connecting with
the Sacred in Everyday Life"
comes to Audible on Thursday.